لماذا صرح طارق السويدان بهذا التصريح
مؤخرا بعد غياب عن المشهد لان هذا هو ما
يعتمل في نفوس جماعه الاخوان المسلمين منذ
سنوات طويله كان كانت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه دائما هدفا لجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين منذ المؤسس حسن البنا وزياراته
المتكرره للسعوديه
ومحاولاته لفتح فرع لجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين في السعوديه ورفض الملك عبد
العزيز رحمه الله
لهذه الرغبه حسب ما ذكره فؤاد شاكر في
كتابه
استمر هذا الحلم وتطور انهم يستهدفون على
الدوام الدوله السعوديه والمجتمع السعودي
والشعب السعودي
لعده اسباب لان السعوديه هي
مهبط الوحي وهي بلاد الحرمين وهي مارز
الايمان وهي
ايضا القدرات كثره الشعب السعودي ايضا
الملائه الماليه في الشعب السعودي قصه
طويله فهم دائما يحومون حول السعوديه
ويستهدفونها بخطاباتهم وفتاويهم ولذلك فهو
يعبر عن مكنون الاخوان المسلمين حينما
يقول حرر الله المسجد الحرام من الحكم
السعودي هذه ليست زله لسان هذه ليست خطا
عابرا هذا هذه هي عقيده اخوانيه راسخه
ولكنه صرح هذه المره بها
عمدا ام خطا هذه قصه اخرى لكن ذلك لا ينقض
ان هذه الفكره اصيله ومتعمقه في خطاب
الاخوان المسلمين وغالب جماعته ربما تذكر
ايضا استاذ عبد الله بشبيهها او نسخه
الاسلام السياسي الشيعي فنعرف ان
الخميني ايات الله الخميني كما يعرف كان
من وصاياه تحرير الحرمين صحيح من السلطه
السعوديه فهنا نقطه تلاقي ايضا بين هذا
هاتين النسختين نقصد الاسلام السياسي
السني والاسلام السياسي الشيعي